The Rock is throwing stones.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson recently took to
Instagram to discuss the box office performance
of his latest flick, Hobbs & Shaw.
As of September 16th, 2019, the first-ever
spin-off film in the Fast and Furious franchise
has earned more than $740 million worldwide.
Johnson posted a screenshot of a Deadline
article confirming Hobbs & Shaw is currently
the best-earning non-superhero, non-Disney
movie of the year, but he also fired shots
at someone in the caption, which read:
"Assassins quietly play chess.
Loud clowns play checkers.
Thank you audiences worldwide for this incredible
support and massive win.
Very cool and we're grateful for the love."
One of the hashtags the actor added was, quote,
"no candy asses", replacing the "e" with a
clown emoji.
"Yeah, I thought it was a cool thing to say
in the moment."
So who's on the receiving end of his diss?
That would be none other than Tyrese Gibson,
a Fast and Furious franchise mainstay with
whom Johnson has been engaged in a drawn-out
and often dramatic feud.
Back when Hobbs & Shaw was first starting
to take shape, Johnson was apparently faced
with a decision: go forward with that film,
or prioritize the ninth Fast and Furious movie,
originally slated to hit theaters on April
19th, 2019, according to The Hollywood Reporter.
Ultimately, Johnson hopped on Hobbs & Shaw,
and it wasn't long after the official announcement
dropped that Fast 9 was pushed back by almost
a year, moving to an April 10th, 2020 release
date.
Johnson later noted that he wouldn't appear
in Fast and Furious 9 at all, according to
The Drive.
It was an outcome that Gibson had desperately
hoped wouldn't happen.
Gibson publicly begged Johnson not to move
ahead with Hobbs & Shaw, writing in a since-deleted
Instagram post, in part,
"If you move forward with that Hobbs movie,
you will have purposely ignored the heart
to heart moment we had in my sprinter.
I don't wanna hear from you until you remember
what we talked about...Fast family is just
that, a family.
We don't fly solo...The Fast 9 release date
has already been announced and we can't let
our loyal fans or our loyal Fast and Furious
fans down on any level from pushing the date...Didn't
you see how HUGE [The Fate of the Furious]
was?
It's because we announced and KEPT our release
date bro."
After Johnson chose Hobbs & Shaw and Fast
9 got delayed, tensions between Gibson and
Johnson continued to flare.
"Alright, I've had enough of this s---."
Gibson blamed Johnson for the Fast 9 delay,
slamming him as greedy and self-centered in
an Instagram post that read, in part,
"Congratulations to The Rock and your brother-in-law
aka 7 bucks producing partner for making the
Fast and the Furious franchise about YOU...Fast
family, right?
Nah.
It's about Team Dwayne."
Gibson later openly dissed Johnson again on
Instagram, accusing him of using steroids
and placing blame on the actor for making
the personal troubles he was dealing with
even worse.
At the time, Gibson called Johnson a clown
and a, quote, "candy ass bitch", two things
Johnson referenced in his recent social media
post.
In early August 2019, just a few days after
Hobbs & Shaw opened in theaters on August
2nd, Gibson posted a screenshot of a news
article that noted the film had posted the
lowest opening weekend for a Fast and Furious
franchise entry since the 2006 launch of The
Fast and the Furious: Tokyo Drift.
The now-deleted post featured a caption that
read, in part,
"Breaking up the family clearly doesn't have
the value that one would assume it does…[Fast
Family] has more value as the [Fast Family]…180
million dollar global opening on Hobbs and
Shaw is NOT a win."
At this point, it doesn't seem like the back-and-forth
bickering between Gibson and Johnson will
stop any time soon.
With Johnson out of Fast and Furious 9, at
least the pair can avoid some potentially
painfully awkward days on set.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
action stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.